I
we were the Grand Master Robert Hess
Robert a couple years ago you finished
second that was a big surprise result
now nobody surprised by you what do you
prefer do you prefer the dark horse we
prefer though the leader tag I think I
prefer where I am right now just in the
middle you know I'm right number five in
this competition and 5 out of 12 it's
right on the middle so like that which
won't play good chess right and you have
always talked about being the kind of
person that kind of wants to start the
gantt move 15 does the first 15 moves
were you more than those key or do you
feel like you've gotten a little better
opening preparation well haven't been
preparing many openings lately I've been
busy at school I prefer to start the
game you know just early as possible I
hate opening theory and I just like the
creativity the game so while my openings
you know they're always gen pretty fine
sometimes they get how played
unfortunate but I feel pretty good and I
know everyone wants to know this is
still a few years down the road what
your plans will be after Yale grad
school chess career tough in the air
have yet to decide down on my major just
been taking a variety of different
classes and having a good time and I'm
just going to put the future to decide
one as a store for me so it sounds like
a cliché to say chess players playing
out their future because it sounds like
you're not planning out so much I have
two very separate lives my chest life
which is here now and there's my school
family friend these are all I separated
into so I live you know for the moment
well as the chessboard I just like to
plan ahead you represented the US the
World Team Championships that what did
that mean to you play for your country I
was a fantastic experience I did pretty
well in the reserve player I got a
silver medal so that really is a
once-in-a-lifetime wants a lifetime
thing more than once but it's a really a
fantastic opportunity to represent your
country
compete against the best in the world
and should you qualify for the Olympia
that'll be right when fall semester
starts would you be able to play anyone
to have to be qualified yeah actually
filed a petition to be excused from play
the first eight days of classes and I
was accepted so if I doing do you
qualify for the limb bed I will be there
for the team in Istanbul Turkey well
good luck trying to win your first US
men's championship thank you